And I ain't saying he's a
gold digger, but-- no, wait.
These guys really
are gold diggers.
Hey, folks.
Laci Green here.
The word Klondike might summon
visions of delicious ice cream
goodness, but it's
time to switch gears
to the Klondike gold rush.
Crazy story, actually.
In the late 1800s, gold
was discovered up in Alaska
in the Klondike river.
Because the area was
so remote, and it was,
you know, the 1800s, it took a
whole year for word to get out.
Once word did get out, 100,000
people uprooted their lives
and headed up to
the Klondike region,
hoping to strike it rich.
But it was a really
difficult journey,
and only about 30,000
people actually made it.
And of those, only a small
fraction, about 4,000 people,
ever found gold.
Today I wanted to talk about
some notable gold diggers
from this fascinating
time in history
where people's hopes,
potential riches,
and the stakes were
all really high.
First up, the man
who's now credited
with starting it
all, James Mason,
better known as Skookum Jim.
Skookum was a Canadian native
who originally packed mining
supplies up the
snowy Chilkoot pass.
Now, this pass was
serious, you guys.
Seven miles through
icy, glacial rocks
that climbed up over 3,000 feet.
Legend has it that
he single-handedly
156 pounds of bacon up the pass.
When he first discovered
the gold at Rabbit Creek,
they panned enough to
fill a shotgun cartridge,
and he went on to make an
estimated $100,000, or three
million today.
Stories about who actually
discovered the gold first
in Klondike are mixed, though.
First, a friend
of Skookum's named
George Carmack was
credited, because nobody
would believe a native.
But there are also accounts of
Kate Carmack, George's wife,
having discovered the gold
while the men were taking a nap.
I'm pretty sure that of all
the successful gold diggers,
Kate Carmack got
the most screwed.
First, possible stolen credit.
But that's nothing
compared to what came next.
During the gold rush, she
and her husband George
panned and made millions.
They moved to Seattle
to enjoy their riches,
but it was hard on both of
them, and they missed their home
in in Dawson.
Instead of allowing Kate to
come back north with him,
George sent Kate to California
to live with his sister,
while he went back alone,
enjoying the lavish life
and courting other women.
And down in
California, Kate tried
to make a legal appeal for
her share of the riches,
but the court denied.
George took all of their
money, and Kate went on
to live off a government pension
in a cabin built by Skookum.
Last of our interesting gold
diggers today, Jack London.
You've probably heard
that name, right?
He wrote one of
my old favorites,
The Call of the Wild.
In his early years, London was
a poor man from San Francisco.
And hoping to
escape unemployment,
he went to UC Berkeley,
my alma mater,
before dropping out
to join the gold rush.
The gold rush itself
wasn't kind to London.
He became malnourished,
developed scurvy,
and struggled with
serious health issues
due to lack of food and shelter.
But it's through these
hardships that Jack
wrote his first successful
story, To Build A Fire.
He went on to become a
very influential socialist
and writer.
Boom.
Redemption.
To learn more about
the gold rush,
check out Discovery's
new miniseries
called, Klondike, which
is premiering Monday
the 20th at 9:00, 8:00 central.
Thanks for joining
me for D News, folks.
I'll see you next time.